when I was 9 years old 7 years old 9
years old I was 8 years old 13 I found
out the truth truth the truth the truth
about Santa Claus not a normal age I
[Music]
thought that Santa was this just magical
fat jolly being every year we would
leave carrots outside around the house
because obviously reindeer love carrots
and then of course the next morning you
wake up and there's little spikes out of
them so clearly Santa and his reindeer
had been there the night before on
Christmas Eve I would always see Santa
literally in our living room leaving our
packages eating my cookies drinking our
milk
I never bothered to think is this guy
real is he fake I remember getting a
piece of paper in the middle of the
night and writing down Santa are you
real and then hiding it under the tree
so that no one knew about it it was just
a kind of thing between me and Santa the
next morning I ended up finding that
same note said yes and I was like he's
real and this was something that I kept
with me for two whole years after
reading a bunch of detective books
started doing some detective work of my
own one day I was cleaning with my mom
we were doing chores I went into the
drawer and the first thing I saw were
these little pink cardboard bunny
footprints that the Easter Bunny used to
put out every year to lead me to my
basket reindeer don't exist in Texas how
can i how can I get Santa to prove to me
that this Rudolph dude is true without
telling my parents I decided to take one
of the carrots and go to sleep with it I
thought that well you know what if the
reindeer are real they're gonna come
into the room at night and bite the
carrot that I'm sleeping with so I asked
Santa in my letter I just would love to
see you and your reindeer and I got a
photo of Santa but no Rudolph
he said that Rudolph was busy working
out and getting ready for the big trek
across the world after winter break you
know you gather around you talk about
what you got for Christmas and that year
I got my dog one of my friends asked me
oh who got him for you and like a split
second before I was about to answer
because
I can say Oh Santa duh one of my other
friends was like well obviously not
Santa because saying it's not real
sure-enough woke up the next morning
with an unbeaten carrot I was like
that's it this is all I needed every
year I was asking for more and more
proof on the 4th year I asked for a bit
of Santa's hair my parents were just
kind of exhausted so I think my mom
started purposely leaving receipts
around the house for gifts that I had
asked for I went to the bathroom where
my mom was this sent to her does this
mean Santa is fake too
and she just went crap it was the week
before we had Christmas break and
everybody was talking about how they
were going to the mall and they were
telling Santa what they wanted and
asking for presents and then there was
this one girl I specifically remember
she was like well I know Santa's real
because last year like I got to talk to
him while he brought me my presents he
showed me a picture that she had with
Santa and I was like that's not Santa
Santa is black and I think our teacher
was kind of at the point where she was
like okay I need to this is turning into
maybe like a little racial argument
because other kids were getting involved
too and when that's when our teacher
decided to tell us you know Santa Claus
isn't real class was ruined I brought up
the note that I wrote to Santa to my
brother and he literally stopped laughed
in my face and said no you idiot that
was just mom writing the note and
putting it back under the tree and I was
completely heartbroken it was the worst
Christmas I've ever experienced
Christmas definitely changed after I
found out that Santa wasn't real and I
remember asking like can I still make a
Christmas list
I actually I don't think I've ever
confronted my mom about it why would a
reindeer come into a sleeping child's
room and bite a vegetable out of a
sleeping child's hand of course that
makes no sense my dad definitely stopped
dressing up as Santa and my parents did
a really good job because the Santa I
always met at the mall was always black
- every time I saw the from Santa tag on
the presents I was just like stare at my
mom and just silently shake my head
that's the story of how I found out that
Santa Claus doesn't exist kids and I
hope this is how you found out
[Music]